good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I am very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022 2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture is supported
by uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and
Sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series is focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will be enjoying presentations
on Fridays at noon eastern time from
leading thinkers on the issues promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health
effects of covet 19. these include
delayed Health checkups treatments
mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus
indeed today we are excited to announce
the opening of our
2022-2023 application cycle and
encouraged Junior faculty members work
in areas such as infectious diseases
epidemiology clinical medicine
population Health as well as data
science machine learning AI statistics
and other relevant domains to consider
applying we believe this will be an
exciting and engaging program where
characterizing the secondary effects of
covid-19 necessitates unique
quantitative approaches but also helps
to develop new multi-disciplinary
collaborations participants in our
biomedical data science uh Innovation
lab program will leverage these seminar
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project
development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edward Andrew sorry Saint
Edwards Park in Seattle Washington in
June of 2023. so today kicking us off
I'm delighted to welcome our speaker Dr
Orlando Lopez from the National
Institutes of dental and and
craniofacial research at the National
Institutes of Health Dr Lopez received
his PhD from the Mayo Clinic and his
Bachelor of Science degree from Boston
University both in biomedical
engineering he is an alumni of the
prestigious FDA Commissioners fellowship
and an NIH postdoctoral intramural
research training award fellow
Dr Orlando Lopez he currently is the
director of the dental materials and
biomaterials program at the National
Institute of dental and craniofacial
research and he contributes to the
programmatic efforts to strengthen
nidcr's biomaterials portfolio and basic
science translational research as it's
dedicated to the restoration and repair
of dental and craniofacial features he's
also manages technology and Innovation
grants under sbir and sttr programs
additionally he oversees interagency
agreements with the National Institutes
of standards and Technology dedicated to
establishing performance standards for
dental materials prior to being at nidcr
Dr Lopez served as the lead regulatory
reviewer
for the the FDA where he led medical
device approvals and imaging
cardiovascular and digital Health
Technologies kicking us off today with
our very first seminar series of this
season Orlando's lecture is entitled rad
medical approaches to covid-19 testing
surveillance surveillance and predicting
susceptibility to developing long
coveted or the pasc task program and so
we are super delighted to have Orlando
and thank you so much for joining us and
getting us started this year Orlando we
look forward to your talk
uh you're you're muted Orlando so you'll
have to unmute okay thank you all right
great so thank you so much Jack on on
June for the kind of invitation to
participate on the very kind
uh introduction as well so thank you uh
so I'm delighted to to be here
um to kick off this uh this series this
really amazing series that uh The
Innovation lab has put together uh to
discuss some of the highlights uh from
the uh radical Raptors generation of
Diagnostics program especially in the
radical aspects of development we've
really been um very excited and very uh
very busy very productive as well in the
past two years addressing this uh Public
Health Emergency Arena so definitely
like to to share some of the highlights
and of course acknowledge uh you know
significant contributions from across
all the different program officers and
the different leadership
aspects of of this initial and under of
course the researchers that are actually
doing the work in the field so
um thanks again and
um let's kick this off here uh
so today I'll be sharing
um different aspects uh and mainly uh at
an over
um overview level around the specific
aspects of some of the Innovation and
the charge of seeking innovation in the
covid-19 testing to address the pandemia
and and the different gaps in that space
looking at some of the discovery and
data Consortium and coordination centers
that are part of this ecosystem of
emerging Technologies as well as uh
provide some key examples
uh that are most relevant to some of
data um considerations that were uh
speaking about in this particular series
um and a newer emerging uh a new a newly
launched initiative on the long-cloud
computational challenge which uh it's
open uh for entries and uh definitely
encourage this community to participate
in that effort as well
so the uh rapid acceleration for
Diagnostics uh covid-19 testing program
um of course uh kicked off early on in
the pandemia uh charge from Congress to
auxiliary innovation in this space and
particularly address the shortage
under on the uh and the actual like
limitations in performance of whatever
was existing because this uh virus was
non-existent before so there was really
no targets uh to to go by but uh the
commercialization piece is also very
important and so a number of different
initiatives can bow uh to address this
uh early on in the pandemia and also
looking uh ahead in terms of long-term
uh developments uh what would be uh some
areas that might be uh a more early
stage
um you know more complex in nature that
needed some additional resources and
time to get to uh you know proof of
concept and viable commercialization
Pathways but uh initially uh the
products that were
most readily accessible and that may be
required just some more of the
manufacturing upscale aspects went into
the Radix Tech program uh which
essentially uh addressed a number of the
different bottlenecks in the early
stages then there were other program
areas that were primarily focusing on
the underserved populations as well as
the testing capacity uh in in clinical
tests testing facilities the particular
program that I'll be talking to uh today
is the radical which is you know aimed
to develop Advanced novel
non-traditional approaches with new
applications not just for covid-19 but
also that have the potential
um in terms of viable platforms for
future uh disease detection and health
monitoring uh you know to address
potential future pandemics and other
aspects of Public Health the data
management support came to be
represented in the context of data
coordination centers that support the
different aspects of the different
programs here and I'll highlight some of
the
um most recent
accomplishments in those spaces so just
to give you a bird's eye view of
um some of the the significant
challenges and also just the chromatic
uh you know complexity in the early
stages that
um the Radix Tech program uh called you
know kicked off a solicitation on
submissions were accepted at the early
stages of epidemia in April uh several
thousand I believe applications came in
and then all those projects were put
through a pipeline kind of like a shark
tank type activity and uh very few
um actually made it all the way but the
ones that made it um you know definitely
got significant support across the board
to be able to to realize those those
goals of of getting
um reliable testing deployed and when we
see that you know of course we still
have a lot of challenges in that space
and and we're trying to address that in
in different areas so from from the
perspective of getting things to Market
is important to consider the overall
biomedical product development cycle and
the different entities and
considerations that are of course make
part of this possible to get something
to Market so initially just you know at
a conceptual level uh starting from the
con the discovery phase ideation of a
project
and then going through uh pre-clinical
assessments I mean that's mainly where
NIH for the most part has a significant
uh role in terms of Bio ecosystem
Innovation ecosystem as the largest seed
fund there for biomedical research in
the world
um and then the the projects ideally
will iterate through a number of uh you
know research development Cycles early
stage characterizations to a point where
um
uh proclinical safety can be
demonstrated primarily in order to start
some human testing then a clinical
testing of course starts and then other
agencies get involved more involved uh
some earlier than others but the FDA of
course is is needed in terms of the
regulatory oversight and then
reimbursement is of course very
important as well so initially clinical
factors for product development are
really I think the key drivers for r d
especially at the early stages and
things that you know are are looked to
go towards that um you know user
adoption Market entry perspective and
you know just like to highlight the
safety piece because a lot of times
innovators want to jump into the
effectiveness right away without
demonstrating that the the Prototype is
even safe so it's important to to
address those aspects and and of course
there's many other layers to consider
that are non-clinical in nature and
especially around the the business
models and and ways to Market that are
course you know that can make or break
projects
this is a you know significant areas of
product development that we have been
discussing and you know addressing and
trying to support a lot of these
Technologies uh so that they can find uh
some streamlined path to Market
especially because uh in the context of
the Radix uh radical program these are
very novel technologies that perhaps
have never been in Market before or at
least not for the particular indications
that we're looking to to support so uh
very closely we've been working with FDA
and other agencies to be able to
leverage uh as much data as possible
from the ecosystem but also to come up
with optimal protocols and and policies
that you know help us support these
emerging Technologies and accelerate
their not just the development but
guided development so that it will be
aligned with regulatory considerations
and requirements in the future so
typically the the value of debt for a
lot of this technology especially in the
space of biomedical uh medical device
space it's the lacking the the design
and doing the pre-clinical
characterization development
verification validation that the
condensed support representative aspects
of the clinical performance
um so that's you know a lot of the the
considerations that we
um look for and uh and the way that we
oversee these type of projects you know
as they accomplish and move forward uh
in their Milestones to to reach the
point where they can either become
Advanced Technologies for clinical
testing or maybe actually enter the
market so again just to highlight the
radical Radix program uh aims to support
the non-traditional approaches including
Rapid detection devices for home-based
testing point of care that address the
the gaps then that was you know two
years ago but there's still significant
aspects of some of the gaps there in
this space but also of course we're
looking for the future and how some of
these platform Technologies company
leverage for future applications
so the portfolio of the Radix rat
program it was a very is very diverse
both from a technology perspective so
about 50 projects were funded initially
in the calendar year 2020 including
multiple novel Technologies across
different reflection schemes different
indications different environments of
use different biomarker targets and of
course addressing different populations
in many different respects
we funded uh I believe 11 or 12
different areas including the data
coordination Center and on each area you
know it's a portfolio within itself the
one that I oversee particularly is the
novel biosensity Technologies for the
oral cavity and iOS participate in a as
a program scientist in other
aspects of The Descent program which is
for detection of development compounds
as well as some of the predictive
prognostic work they'll be talking to
briefly but yeah so about uh 100 or so a
million dollars were awarded to his
projects and we're working uh with uh
some of the projects that are more
advanced in nature some of them have not
received additional support supplemental
funds to get into to the next phase of
the of the r d and and even to some of
the scalability and uh of the product
development as well as some of the
regulatory
um streamlining of the of the evaluation
is there to get to Market so highlight I
will highlight a couple of uh examples
from some of the novel biosensing
activities as well as the scent program
or scanning for covid-19 by electronic
nose and then some of the Wastewater
detection as well as uh some of the data
coordination aspects as well so for the
uh
the enabling Technologies the oral
devices
um
Technologies were really the foundation
for the Radix rad call that we put
together
um uh from nitcr the National Institute
of dental and current official research
so we have uh invested in previous years
prior to the pandemia on the development
of very novel techniques uh to leverage
the oral cavity
um as a way of access to not just the
oral cavity itself but you know the rest
of the body where we can look for
potential indicators of overall health
and disease and and leverage that
accessibility for Discovery Diagnostics
and Therapeutics and so the oral cavity
from an engineering perspective is is
quite a challenge
um you know there's many different
forces a lot of chemical uh extremes
temperatures and of course you know
everybody eats and it sleeps and you
know everybody has a different you know
their own routine and so uh having uh an
indwelling device device that will go
into the oral cavity and remain there
for some time and and remains uh you
know robust in its performance over time
uh it's quite a challenge but but if
that can be accomplished
um and in meaningful ways uh it could be
a very powerful
uh platform
um you know for for looking at health
and overall health
um in the future and so uh that came as
a platform or Baseline for the Radix rat
um call and we combined with uh work
with our colleagues at ncat uh to
combine these programs
um and uh and came up with a number of
different activities and and we are
supporting 11 different projects in this
area
um so this this was the call um that was
put out in 2020 and um and in the other
uh call from the uh ncats on The Descent
program basically looks to Leverage The
the ability of canines you know to uh
send uh different aspects I mean there's
been some some reports and and
verifications of of canines detecting
being able to detect cancer or diagnose
uh diabetes and many other aspects so
we're looking to mimic that capability
into an electronic form that could uh be
used for uh covid-19 but also you know
of course other other areas in the
future so um look in a very developed
development of this novel Technologies
uh looking at unconventional detection
strategies and um and access and
usability
some some example technologies that have
emerged from from some of these programs
um very exciting around contact tracing
with privacy protection
um so of course you know privacy
protection has been a you know the
Forefront of a lot of data sharing and
privacy aspects you know for for
identity insecurity considerations of of
users uh but uh but at the same time
there's of course significant value in
being able to
identify uh and uh you know on track the
potential
um folks that are infected in this type
of scenario and so uh this this
particular development allows for
de-identified user inputs uh and um you
know looking at the locations I've been
able to actually have a user reported
positives and what you can see here in
the uh in the graph there the color
graph you can see that there is a
there's an ability to
um connect the dots and look at a
distance level to be able to assess you
know whether or not somebody's has a
level of risk or
um for you know Contracting disease and
should be part of the contact tracing
and so on so uh this is a blockchain
based platform and you know this type of
technology has of course a lot of
different possibilities and potential in
in this area but other areas as well uh
from the from The Descent program
um we have been able to uh get to a
point where some of these Technologies
can actually uh detect uh you know covet
positive versus uh covet negative
patients uh just from uh different uh
volatiles that have been analyzed from
Excel breadth and so this is uh very
exciting
um there had been no FDA approved
products for volatile organic compound
detection or to be used as Diagnostics
uh there was one that came up this past
year
um and so that kind of sets the
precedent for this type of Technologies
to potentially you know move forward and
get more advanced so some of the of the
different capabilities are basically uh
you know through the functionalization
of materials that get bound to you know
specific uh binding agents or targets uh
related to the covid-19 virus or some
other uh Excel breath chemical and
that's put through a process for
detection of these volatiles in in the
vapor form uh some of the protocols for
the breath analysis basically covers the
uh taking the bread sample in a bag uh
the the the the material the gas
materials then pass through a
pre-concentrator of of these volatiles
there's some gas hematography that is
conducted there is a different you know
levels of processing uh microfluoretics
and then typically there is of course
you know significant layers of machine
learning AI algorithms that crunch
through all these different Spectrum the
Spectra that are produced for all these
different chemical entities and uh and
then they're spit out some type of risk
factor or some type of indicator that
could help clinical decision on the
diagnostic so this is maybe some of the
of the Spectra that come out of this
type of Technologies
which are then analyzed and then from
there there is a determination of of the
detection of a particular compounds or
or the signature of a particular
combination of compounds that might be
representative of whether or not
somebody has a disease or the infection
this is uh more data looking at
non-covet and covet there was even some
uh there has been some demonstrations
around the detecting differences between
the different uh variants of the virus
and so this is you know really really
encouraging and you know these
researchers have done some outstanding
work to get this technology to where it
is and we're very much looking forward
to getting this uh you know more further
developed
um now to not shift gears a little bit
to uh the Wastewater detection of sarsko
V2 uh this has of course been um uh
really very Innovative
um sorry there's a
alarm going by
um so yeah the uh the Wastewater
detection aspect you know of course uh
came to uh to be considered a
significant uh significant tool or
potential tool to address uh the
prediction of of the uh covid-19
infections through uh more more at a
public health level a community level
um and so this is have been really
exciting um from a environmental
perspective and many others as well uh
so some of the goals for for this
program have been around the
investigation of specific approaches uh
that could aim to to inform and optimize
um not just the sampling but also the
the detection of these waste Waters uh
demonstration and optimization of of the
sample analysis and then development of
uh intervention strategies that could
actually make best use of this data and
the information gathered from it which
uh in many in many ways could be very
unique
um and incorporate that into of course
um more advanced computational
techniques that that could be used for
for uh prediction
um so some of the advantages uh for this
approach
um could be that it could be a really
broad coverage across you know different
municipalities uh local entities it
could be very cost effective cheaper and
faster than clinical screening so like
doing patient by patient
um there is some some significant
demonstrations of indications of
Wastewater content and correlations to
covid-19 and that has been demonstrated
a number of different
reports and papers
um and so so yeah so there's you know of
course a significant value here as well
as the the ability to complement other
approaches and be able to just you know
make uh for for a stronger decision
making the more data that we have from
from different perspectives different
risk factors
um so there were six projects that have
been funded through this initiative and
and they're all moving forward uh very
productively
um and so of course data is key so
um like I mentioned there's the Radix
rat program uh has a data coordination
Center component to it which supports
Administration and operations and the
logistics of some of data intake and
sharing from across the different
projects
um and uh and the data management and
use as well as supporting researchers in
different ways and so with that I'll
segue to into some of the updates from
that
um the discovery and the data Consortium
coordination Center which is led by Dr
Lucilla Machado as well as Dr Shu and Dr
Spencer and they have um also kindly
provided some some slides
um to provide some updates on this and
so so this schematic outlines this cup
of work of the Radix DCC now as you can
see the project led by by the different
awardees the awarding team it's still
early early in the well it's not early
but early in the in the program DCC
worked closely with the NIH to arrive at
a minimum set of common data elements
for cdes to be collected by all awardees
working with human samples
since uh they were the DC the DCC since
then the DCC continues to spearhead uh
the formulation of common data elements
for research uh or scientific domain
um specific ones also known as tier 2
cdes
um here the the the new work process
have been developed to support the wide
variety of projects included in the
Radix rad program
the DCC
um also built tools for the
identification and limited linkage of
patients for use by the orders the
identification was focused on
safeguarding information related to
certain
um personal uh and file information
which are targeted by the NIH for
infectious disease such as zip code
which reduce the the first three digits
only
um the age shifted by by plus minus two
years and and dates of care measurements
uh were adjusted to minus or five plus
you know of plastics
it is important to note that the Radix
threat program early in the definition
required all award is to submit only the
identified data according to the
requirements approved by the NIH
leadership
and this was important as uh as it
allowed for the Raptor transfer of data
to the NIH Radix data Hub and interim
and in turn to the researchers who have
interest in the data
um then the final as mentioned earlier
the DCC also provide Benchmark samples
to our word ease so that they can
normalize and ensure their programs are
verified using a defined bench Benchmark
the DCC
um the gathers all the data from the 50
awardees collates them verifies that
there are no residual
um personal identifiable informations uh
in the data to a global and transfers
this to a global code book that was
developed later in the program
um and submit them along with the
original submission to the NIH terahub
which in turn receives data from other
dccs such as the Radix Tech or Radix up
so here the page provides a quick
snapshot of work accomplished
unrecorded by the Radix rad data Hub as
mentioned earlier uh there are 50
awardees the 49 uh scientific awardees
and and the one is the BCC as part of
the Radix program right extract program
uh of the 49 awardees 40 awardees have
shared data with the DCC including about
21 with multiple submissions in order to
facilitate common data elements the VCC
has held over 100 tier two CDE meetings
and has made significant progress in
some areas such as Wastewater exosome
and sent
um
the DCC has also shipped
close to 500 samples to the awardees for
their use to Benchmark their work
another important role played by the
Radix rad is to provide guidance toward
these in their interactions with the FDA
and the DCC has arranged 22 search
meetings and help that were these
prepared and make best use of the
audience with the FDA the DCC has also
held 34 were these prepare applications
for resources one 10 licensing
agreements and are in place between
awardees and commercialization
organizations
um you can see a few more statistical
information in the other
in the other slides
so
now just a quick summary of the
highlights
um we have spoken about the minimum of
the tier 2 cdes led by the Radix Radley
CC and they have also provided a
prescriptive templates for the data
dictionary that can be leveraged
existing that can leverage existing or
new
um or new surveys
uh we have also spoken about the Privacy
technology and tools provided by BCC
another important support by DCC has
been to help the awardees navigate their
institutional irbs particularly for
organizations that are not academic uh
institutions that have fewer established
work processes
um data analysis report and
methodologies is provided to our these
particularly leveraging cross-learning
is facilitated by the Radix rat DCC of
course one of the key roles is to allow
the smooth and Flawless upload by their
word is and on the NIH data hub
the Radix rad DCC has been instrumented
instrumental in uh in working with the
NIH Radix red hub to evaluate new tools
methods and procedures
the DCC has filled a vital Gap to
provide tools to the awardees they need
uh to consistently and correctly meet
the identification of their data and
this is uh you this is used by several
about 10 or so of deliveries who have
patient information of a total of 20 who
have patience the others work with
synthetic or non-identifiable patients
the the quality assurance tools allow
for automatic screening of a word
compliance with metadata data dictionary
and data files
um contain constraints for the Radix
thread data hub
so from a work process Improvement the
the the main work work process was to
develop a method for building data
dictionaries that would function across
a wide range of radically different
programs the DCC has made significant
progress in this and developed it the
second area is related to the dbgap
registration as dbgap is an NIH
established identifier to streamline
access to secure data such as that
gather under the NIH Radix program the
DCC has worked
with awardees and has obtained
registrations of 47 awardees and finally
the DCC has developed new work processes
that has facilitated Flawless upload of
the data to the um you know STP FTP and
is actively engaged with supporting
awardees to support uh and submit their
data to other Repository stories across
NIH and others as well
so here are just some statistics and the
interest of time I'm not going to go
through them but you know I kind of
mentioned some of those already
and uh this is he has definitely played
a significant
um and crucial role in supporting a lot
of these projects
um now
shift gears to
um
sorry this is another from from another
meeting I borrowed this uh these slides
but uh this is for the long covet
competitional Challenge and
um this is another very exciting
opportunity and a newly launched
um challenge price competition
um that uh and we will provide a brief
overview on the objectives of this
Challenge and information on how you can
participate and the breakdown of the
price per totaling up to five hundred
thousand dollars uh everyone is welcome
to participate in this Challenge and we
definitely appreciate
um you know the members the audience uh
spreading the word on this uh the uh the
submission period uh was from when he
was launched in August 25th and uh
submissions will be received until
December 15th of this year
so I'd like to acknowledge the NIH
leadership and all the contributors that
have
um you know made some efforts uh to put
together and launch these ChalleNGe
Program uh there had been a there has
been a number of contributors from
across NIH many different programs uh
including I'd like to also highlight and
acknowledge my co-chairs for this
program I'm one of the co-chairs for for
the for the challenge as well as Dr
Aaron iteriaga Yvonne Schulman
um and uh Chen also contributed
significantly to this to this particular
program
so the community challenge is an NIH
long
um covet computational challenge it's a
community Challenge and a community
challenge is a is a crowdsourced
benchmarking effort which aims to
accelerate research by seeding and
strengthening a research community and
addressing an important scientific or
biomedical question the format of a
challenge is
broken into three parts first comes the
question then to build and then the
Benchmark the question is a research
question that the challenge organizers
pose and is the guidelines that the
focus of the research Community uh to
the topic that the NIH is interested in
the build is the portion of the
challenge where the participants build a
method to answer the question and The
Benchmark points to
um The Challenge where the challenge
organizers judge the build or method
that the participants created against a
set of gold standards
so the challenging tends to accelerate
the innovation of software tools to
improve understanding of risk factors
and support the clinical prognosis of
long covet
now for an overview of the l3c
Challenge and uh just a quick background
on the
condition the actual clinical driver for
this is uh that the overall prevalence
of post-acute sequela of sarskovic II
also known as pasc uh and and as well as
long covet are currently unknown but
there is growing evidence that more than
half of covid-19 survivors experience at
least one symptomatic pass for long
covet at least six months after recovery
from acute illness uh the long-term
effects are on persistent symptoms of
covid-19 uh can affect anyone including
children and it can be um you can
developing people who had asymptomatic
mild or severe disease reports also
reflect an underlying heterogeneity of
symptoms multi-urgan involvement and
Persistence of pass or long covet in
some patients
symptoms of fatigue cognitive impairment
shortness of breath and cardiac damage
among others have been observed in
patients who had only mild initial
disease despite ongoing research and
significant need
remains in identifying prognostic
factors that can reliably support
clinical decisions for the management
and prevention of past long covet in
sarskovic to infected individuals
foreign
complexity of data created in today's
Health Care encounters require Advanced
analytics to extract meaning from
longitudinal and data on symptoms
laboratory results images functional
tests genomics mobile health and
wearables written notes ehrs and and
other relevant data types Advanced
developments of software tools and
Computing capacity has allowed
artificial intelligence and machine
learning approaches that are
increasingly demonstrating the potential
to provide insight into patient level
data from large amount of data to better
understand the effect of Sarasota on
patients
to complement other NIH long coveted
research initiatives like the research
in covet to enhanced recovery program
that are known as recover the Radix rack
program at the NIH launched a long
coveted computational challenge also
referred to as the l3c to support
Creative data-driven Solutions that
meaningfully Advance the current
understanding of the risk to developing
past and local covet
challenge participants will utilize the
the identified electronic health record
data available to the incats and 3C data
Enclave The Enclave is a central
harmonized data repository that
represents electronic health records
from over 74 Healthcare centers across
the U.S and to protect patient privacy
the identified data provides information
useful to researchers without revealing
any information that could identify
individual patients and for the
information on the n3c might be
available in a couple more slides but
there is definitely the links that folks
can refer to for additional information
and also uh to ask questions about you
know some of this program
um so in terms of the objectives of the
program
uh the l3c challenge uh aims to focus on
the prognostic problem by developing AI
commission learning models and
algorithms that serve as open source
tools for using structured medical
records to identify which patients
infected with sarskovic 2 have a high
likelihood of developing task or long
covet
understanding risk factors may help
clinicians better understand the
underlying etiology of the past and long
covet condition models will be evaluated
using patients who have had an ICD 10
code related to to the disease and
recorded in the data set and label as
true positive of patients with past or
long covet and future funding
opportunities related to this topic may
become available uh if this channel
Beyond this challenge announcement
depending on the state of the science uh
Public Health need at that point and
availability of funds for for further
development of of these models and
algorithms uh into more advanced tools
that can support clinical decision
making not just for covid-19 but maybe
for other areas as well
so one of the one of the challenge as
one of the challenges of the challenge
is that um
we have a you know there's definitely a
issue with the definition of past and
long covet
um the the working definition continues
to change uh with new evidence and is
challenging given that it encompasses a
multi-organ effect uh and and seen in
this disease
um covid-19 positives are defined for
this challenge as patients who have had
a positive covid-19 PCR test not just a
diagnosis and we Define
patients who have had an ICD-10 code
recorded in data set as true positives
there will be further explanation
um and there is also a recorded uh
webinar on this and so I think I'm gonna
just kind of skip through all this but
uh most folks are eligible uh to
participate there is some challenge
participation rules that uh are provided
uh in this website these are two that
you know we like to highlight The Prize
winners
um are expected to deploy their solution
uh as open source uh resource to the
community and so the recently the prices
contingent on that and there is also
um you know requests or requirements for
having established data use agreement to
be able to use the data within the n3c
Enclave so definitely a point folks to
to those resources and and just to
become familiar with with the rules
there
so in terms of the n3c
repository
um
the the data represents over 15 million
patients uh it's I believe that the
largest repository in the world for
covet related data and that's what we're
going to be using uh the data set
includes information such as
demographics symptoms and so on you know
like a lot of the EHR type of
information there is observational
medical outcomes and partnership
um in the model the model is the one
that is used typically for getting the
data on and harmonizing it and the ic-10
ICD-10 code is is basically the uh the
ground Truth uh in within the the
database but uh you know folks are able
to bring in other creative ways to um
to check against that that's also very
welcome
so there is the there is access to the
data and so establishing access to the
n3c and click uh it's the does the
required data set
um and people will have access to the uh
sequester data that has been reserved
for this Challenge and so everybody has
to go through that process
um the timeline
um we submitted the paperwork uh in yeah
and so sorry the uh this is for the n3c
Enclave onboarding
um of the enclave and so submissions are
due by the 15th of December
and the winners are going to be and I'm
gonna pass Bridge through these but
there is of course uh judging uh
criteria the first prize will have um
uh part of 200 000 second price of 150
the third prize 100 000 and there will
be five projects that will be selected
for honorable mentions of 50k each
and these are some of the resources and
links that folks can follow up with uh
to um ask you know to have more
information about the challenge but as
well as to submit their questions
so with that I thank you for your
invitation again and your kind patience
uh definitely be happy to address any
questions that I can thank you so much
Orlando thank you so much that was a
really great overview of this kind of
really exciting opportunity
um some of the activities which have
been going on uh at the NIH concerning
uh covid and monitoring Technologies and
and so forth what an exciting uh
opportunity for anybody who wants to
kind of get involved in and get access
to uh some of that data from the uh uh
the n3c in particular just as a little
aside um Johanna lumba who is one of the
people that you mentioned on your uh
your uh committee that's putting uh some
of the challenges together she's going
to be um taking part in our efforts here
um through our biomedical data science
Innovation lab we're hoping to have her
come join us in Seattle next summer to
uh talk and uh about the data and to
present it um more formally and get
people engaged with it so we're super
excited about that one question I wanted
to have for you or that I have for you
is
um what are some of the roles for that
people who are data scientists that are
what what extra things could they do if
they were able to get access to this
data one of the things you mentioned was
um on some of these Technologies some of
the safety and the effectiveness of that
data or or the the Technologies which
are being produced would any of the data
be available to for people who are so
interested to say get access to it
available through the dccs
um and like look at elements of safety
and effectiveness of these various
Technologies
uh sure no thank you that's a great
question
um well I at this point um I'm not sure
exactly if the data is available openly
but it's been is being acquired
um not all projects are able to
contribute in the same way uh some are
sbirs ttrs like Small Business Awards
and some of those projects of course
have um you know IP protection
confidentiality considerations and so
not all the data will be available but
but I think in if not available now in
due time there might be some data that
might become available from uh from some
of the DCC
repositories that have been put together
so uh this is uh it's been about like a
two and a half year effort so far and so
DCC started from scratch basically and
so they have been working very
diligently to to structure the intake of
data and formulate all the processes and
so on so I would expect that you know
some availability of data might become
uh you know not now down the pipe
that's fantastic and
um I the uh
ChalleNGe Program that you described uh
is super exciting will be super exciting
for people who are
um interested in this particular topic
and I'm curious if you anticipate the
challenges happen more challenges
happening in the future around other
elements that leverage these data
oh absolutely I think that that that's
um that's something that we are
exploring
um this uh l3c uh challenge is
um a first challenge in in this in this
space at least for us and um so it's
definitely been a learning lesson also
for us I mean NIH and certain uh groups
within NIH are of course Very Savvy and
very experienced uh running challenges
in many different
um in many different areas you know
addressing very different topics
um so we are definitely learning from
this experience and like I mentioned uh
in the presentation for their future
funding might become available around
this particular topic and so it depends
on the outcome of this challenge I guess
we'll make some determinations as to you
know maybe having additional uh
calls or leveraging this type of
mechanism for other areas so that's to
be determined but uh but it's a it's a
very exciting way to um and to
accelerate Innovation
um especially in a in a space that uh
that's very much of in need but there is
very exciting uh potential technologies
that could help address uh some of those
challenges so so it's definitely a great
way to to leverage and maximize value
across the way so definitely see that as
happening more often uh I just don't
know exactly how that will become part
of the process here right right well it
would just be uh the the timing for your
December 15th deadline here for our
biomedical data science Innovation lab
activities doesn't quite line up that
would be a little too quick for us but
uh if there were a second phase that
dealt with other dimensions of covid
related data that's available through
the n3c for example or for maybe
something's available from the folks at
San Diego from the DCC that were
available for a secondary challenge it
was due next uh I don't know next fall
for example our biomedical data science
Innovation lab teams that are going to
be forming would be in pole position to
be able to compete with clever projects
for uh for those challenges
um
yeah I noticed it's um another a number
of the you mentioned one in particular
project that was looking at kind of
contact maps of people who you know and
using the blockchain technology to kind
of anonymously keep track of people in
their contacts and whatnot and um that
looked like that just from eyeballing
the slide it looked like it depended
heavily upon graph Theory and network
Theory and that is certainly something
that's a particular interest to folks in
this community I'm curious if you could
say a little bit more about that
particular project or any of the success
stories that it has had
um yeah well unfortunately I'm not
always overseeing that particular
project
um okay I'll be happy to you know to
provide the uh the contact for the
program officer that is leading that
um so yeah so I'm not you know uh sort
of up to speed on on the specifics of
that project besides the uh the high
level
um you know overview that I provided but
uh but I am very familiar with a lot of
the blockchain type Technologies and so
in general uh of course you know they
have significant potential uh in the
context of uh provenance uh immutability
um yeah and being able to really
establish trust uh on a robust way to uh
to have reliable data uh so in that in
that context uh I think that that
decentralization of of elements um uh I
think sets well for this particular
Network approach of contact raising
because uh that is of course an
important piece there the identification
element I think that that's a unique way
also to
leverage a lot of this data and so
looking at Federated learning systems
and graph theory of course you know
facilitates a lot of the the the
correlation or the mapping of
of different uh data assets or different
you know information
um elements and so I can definitely see
you know these Technologies uh becoming
more and more uh you know part of of
this platform or this type of platforms
for the future as as these Technologies
of course become more
more available and and folks are
becoming more in tune with their value
because I think still some element of of
blockchain in particular compared to to
AI That's still somewhat fuzzy to to
folks uh uh but nonetheless I think uh
you know there's no single like Silver
Bullet so I think it's the combination
of a lot of this technologies that
um very cleverly integrated uh can can
definitely deliver value and address a
lot of the significant aspects of uh you
know what what are some of the emerging
concerns with this
um you know digital Technologies and
connected Healthcare including some
other tips elements I'm very involved in
one of the IEEE
um standard development around the uh
the integration interoperability of of
clinical iot uh data and devices and uh
we're looking to address the tips
component so the trust identity uh
privacy Protection security and safety
mode uh in addition to that of course we
need to think about the ethical
components and a number of other aspects
in that in that line of of
um development of these Technologies in
addition to the safety and the
effectiveness which are you know sort of
the underlying performance requirements
but now that we're bringing in all these
other emerging texts we need to start
thinking about
um you know other elements on how to
build trust
um you know in the ecosystem and of
course by the patients and the clinical
users that are going to be relying on
them
yeah it was interesting when um the the
contract contact tracing
um the digital Technologies I was on a
trip in Europe and
contacted contracted covid uh when I got
home and I got a notification after I
had recovered through my phone that I
had been in contact with somebody while
I was on my European trip which was a
little too little too late so obviously
some further technology technological
development needs to happen but one
thing which is particularly interesting
is the waste water
um Technologies and one could imagine
these being deployed in the Wastewater
management system of a particular
building of a village
um a town and then being scaled up to
cities I'm I'm curious if there are any
technologies that will be scalable to be
able to assess you know not only
individual homes but maybe communities
as well
um yeah well that's a that's a great
vision uh and I I believe that that's
probably part of the plan to to some of
this
um I think at this point we're still
um at the high level
um sort of verification and validation
stage that there's been of course some
some very uh promising reports on on
this uh in terms of like being able to
use Wastewater
um detection for covid-19 and and being
able to predict uh a new wave of of
infection maybe about two weeks or so in
advance and so that's uh that's
definitely very promising and so from
from a number of different
um considerations in the context of
Public Health surveillance I think that
this will just become uh in time just
another tool in our arsenal of uh you
know this emerging like novel techniques
that are really I think very powerful
and and when they are validated which is
I think the you know the significant
part of the challenge but once we have
them embedded and well established I
think that you know this all together
will really change the the the Paradigm
of how Healthcare
um it's is actually practiced in many
aspects uh by accessing reliable
information to really enhance decision
making so I think that's a very exciting
future ahead of us
Orlando I want to thank you so much for
summarizing uh all these different
activities that the NIH has going on
um these are all very exciting it's I
think would be very appealing for a lot
of our potential participants and as
sources of data or sources of
inspiration to kind of think deeply
about where data science could play a
role some of the computational
Technologies which could be deployed to
help in terms of the technology for uh
kind of early detection for long-term
tracking for discriminating between
different coveted uh variants Etc it's
all super exciting
um I want to encourage everybody uh to
consider applying for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab activity uh
the deadline will be January 8th and
applications are being received up until
that point
um there'll be a priority for folks who
apply early this result the part of the
program is taking part in a few online
activities in addition to these seminar
series as well as being able to take
part in our in-person activity um to be
held in Seattle Washington next June uh
check out our website
innovation.lab.virginia.edu for further
information and uh and application
materials as well once again Orlando
thank you so much uh this has been
wonderful and uh I hope that uh anybody
who has any questions for Orlando will
reach out to him directly and we want to
thank you and we'll everyone have a
great weekend we'll see you all soon
thank you so much